I'm thinking of confession because of
wars been running for good ten minutes
and life changed it's not change that's
exactly why thing and then when I do get
into it I think that they're thinking oh
wow
[ __ ] you know what is this 24 23 24 24 I
think I don't know cocky pop man so sng
family amps if you like us on YouTube
like the thing if you want to comment
say with your chest if you like to
listen subscribe on whatever platform
you like to listen to and if you're a
true fan and you're not some kind of
[ __ ] [ __ ] tease and [ __ ] that
likes free content become a patreon
patreon become a patron on our patreon
page so patreon is our new flex become a
patron support the show obviously you
know we want to do this full-time so
let's make magic happen just go to
patreon
it's and gigs podcast for exclusive
content for as little as 3 pound a month
British sterling I don't know what that
translates to in other countries but
it's probably around the same that's
probably it would be around this yeah
it's cheap as [ __ ] basically so yeah
subscribe
obviously we rex it happened not long
ago so the pound is low low low so your
your jumped in on a bargain we've done
you man yeah we've done you mother they
ask me if I want to put it in dollars I
said now let me let me keep me a bit
about let me keep it budget for these my
minimum if you're feeling saucy you can
go 10 20 there's different tiers for
different benefits so jump on patreon
forward slash chasing gigs podcasts
alright we live I mean I ask you saying
yeah hmm you say it's [ __ ] good this
one love monster bruv I love the monster
I love monster I love it I love it [ __ ]
it let me go on monster for a minute hmm
you ma'am
I love monster if you don't want to
subscribe to the patreon thing send me
once I need I need
box for you man send me [ __ ] ultra
monster sugar-free I don't drink coffee
and none of that [ __ ] any my caffeine
kicks I love [ __ ] monster it makes me
feel amazing I love drinking on Pocket
me it just makes me feel so good yeah
like I just feel like I want to talk I
wanna like Batman of like I was here
like people like when you said about
like being baked and being high whatever
you just feel emotional yeah and you
feel loved and you feel what is it
that's how I feel when I fit when I've
got a from one start really it makes me
feel amazing like it makes me want to be
super positive and just likes a really
nice [ __ ] about people okay and tell
people I love them and stuff like that
if I've ever text you said I [ __ ]
love you yeah I'm probably drinking the
moss for as we speak I love it I love it
it's gonna give me cancer probably what
he has but oh but it's worth it so we're
for sale espera I'll survive it
stainless so I could drink 1:1 stuff
what lengths have you gone to here to
ensure that the opposite sex like your
partner girlfriend or something hasn't
heard you [ __ ] or far that's a great
question
or not even just heard you have it
doesn't know you shat and doesn't know
you're by oh god I smell it can't hear
it god that's a great question
well to my knowledge I don't think I've
ever well I probably have but probably
deep sleep like fired in bed with a girl
or if I have oh my god no there was one
time a cover-up which got it was this
was probably a few years ago I remember
I was you know me the fall wakes you up
yes I do that was what it was but I
prayed to God she wasn't awake it
rattled me cuz I was just breathing yeah
I was breathing do you me sleep it and
then all of a sudden bang I fired it
woke me up but the funny thing was I was
facing one way she was facing back to
back yeah back to back thing so I didn't
want it then now move after it to see
what was she commenting so I stayed
still my eyes open balls frozen I was
froze her for about a good four five to
make sure there was no movement that was
there oh my that that was a close call
coming who was that was a close call but
apart from that I always I think I
always tend to I would have a [ __ ] when
I'm about to shower yeah get that just
stay out of the way lock the door just
don't come in a bro bro bro bro or I'm
playing music so you can't hear a thing
and I do it when like let's say she's in
my room while she's in the living room
you know I mean fire and I feel like I
just do it as and when I can just swipe
in when it comes to shittin I do it
tactically
I have to do it either just before I'm
showering or yeah I think that's the
only time I do if not I'm holding it
hold it until until I can go I'm a
gentleman it's a life is I wanna
intentionally fall in front of someone I
would never intentionally do it no bear
man will do when they comfortable in
their relationship they're doing it bro
no god I've everything we've can ever
say James farts if I do so accident or
I'm asleep or something firm if I'm in
the females president I thought will
always wake me up always wake me up I'd
be like I'm panics buddy I've got three
is it three hang on hang on hang on
three situations yeah this is how
there's three situations I don't even
know if we'll get through them all yeah
that like have been the most mortifying
experiences in terms of like being
around females yeah and like fighting
slash shittin yeah if anyone thought I
was remotely attractive before this
episode yeah I'm fine with it
I'm open broy ship so that was one time
right let's keep it like so I start with
the farts and it's annoying because I
[ __ ] hate like I'm a grown-ass man
and nothing really embarrasses me yeah
but if I accidentally fight in front of
someone yeah I don't think I can go red
but I would go red yeah and so I hope
that's one time so how do I say this
[ __ ] so
you know you can perfect a silent one in
it you wait until it's Antilles here
breathing in a breeze and he just yeah
bro and it's just and it just goes into
the atmosphere and the you like calm
calm cool perfect the silence are
perfected that so obviously women no men
no men like you got a bit of hair on
your back in here a little bit hair
anybody so I didn't know that the little
bit of fluff you have on your ass
actually benefits with the the fur okay
with the the fighting thing right okay
so it helps the silent nurse I don't
know if it's a cushion between your
cheeks or whatever and it just helps it
beside I didn't know that so check this
out when when me and figured used to be
naked but let's as we've said before I
used to shave every hair on my body I
used to shave every hair on my body yeah
so I were going to see women while I'm
naked and I forgot fluff on my ass I'm
just not I'm just yeah I shaved
everything I was hairless I part my legs
but I was hairless yeah I would even
trim the hair on my legs or whatever I
just wanted to be yeah I was trying to
be hairy yeah yeah I want the part so
obviously first couple times we did it
said researchers what did we think
anything of it so we've gone to I've got
a job coming up I'm in a relationship at
the time I've got a job coming up and
I've also done my normal manscaping
removed all my hair everything come to
do the job next day or whatever my
girlfriend at the time comes her on to
see me we're in bed and I've got a
little rumble rumble in my tummy in it
so I'm not I think far so like you said
you let it travel this own way you deal
with your discomfort infernal yeah and
you're just watching a film yeah yeah
and it's just like doing this ting and
you're like position yourself position
so some there edge up onto the side and
obviously we're under the covers in it
so I'm locking
exit points yeah so if you ever seen me
sleep like shoulder if you ever see me
cut up like tuck tucked into bed
I need apart yeah cuz I don't know what
any gas escaping I don't know what's
been enough in fact yeah but I can't I
can't hold it anymore yeah so I'm not
alright let me perfect the silent yeah
movie movie movie and ready for the
silent but I've got no fluff to die
separate my ass cheeks so I thought
think it is gonna be silent from my
cheeks were clapping it literally
sounded like this row it sounded so
fresh and literally just all you hear is
me like I've never been so more it was
loud oh my day loud my cheeks were
slapping slapping I couldn't believe it
I couldn't [ __ ] believe it you say
bro she just laughed she laughed and
expected me to laugh cuz she was open
like that she was open I expected me to
if I weren't laughing I would have been
mortified mortified I would have wanted
to swallow me whole I couldn't live
through that I was not gonna cry again
no I couldn't look at her again I
couldn't I was awful that's funny it was
the worst experience funny um second
time same girl bro that's naked ass
cheeks just slapping she was right it
was disastrous second time second time
just saying go she took me on a trip to
Madrid you know how is now innit
yeah okay cool so took me on trips in
Madrid we were there as soon as we got
into the hotel this is why [ __ ] hate
hotels hotels and apartments because the
bathroom don't have no ventilation
system and I needed to Brock yeah so I
told her just gonna jump in a shower so
she's like cool jumped in the shower
obviously when in same true kind of
shower on music
music God had a [ __ ] and had a
tremendous Duke so drop there finish my
[ __ ] I'm like bless cool wipe my bat II
got in the shower wash wash wash wash
wash I don't know how I must have
forgotten to wash my [ __ ]
I don't know how this happened I must I
just must have I thought I did but for
the sake of story I'm telling you I must
not okay
so jump out the shower I'm feeling fresh
yeah I've had my [ __ ] the fumes are kind
of absorbed by the the shower rubbed out
bless so we've got all these white
towels around and just drying myself off
from go to dry your back my butt I look
at the towel no no no no no no no no no
I don't want me to do I found the
biggest streak of [ __ ] the biggest
streak of [ __ ] and I'm just like now now
and we're you drying yourself in the
room with her no bathroom in the
bathroom so I'm thinking we're not ready
you hide the problem and there's bad
glass in this bathroom from there it was
like new a Josiah just glass
everything's glass the sink is glass the
shelves about everything's glass I can't
hide it anywhere and I'll just like [ __ ]
and then I'm like [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] so I
must have used that towel yeah
use another towel yeah I think was the
Tyler put my foot yeah I'm like here to
get out of shower and when I got out of
there I dashed it on the floor
so I scrambled them up yeah - time on
the floor next to the door yeah I said
ah they'll pick him up yeah we were
about to go out and I was like oh I'll
put the thing on the door so they change
our towels straightaway so when we come
back tonight we've got strew fresh cows
fam we get changed we're ready go to go
out as she's gone to open the door she
looks down and she's like what is that
and I'm like what she's like on the
towel like it's dirty and I'm like I
look and I'm like I didn't even see that
yeah like it is she
she's like that is a [ __ ] and I was like
I guess but I don't think it is and it's
so bad I was like no it was I'm sure it
was clean when I but so I pretended I
picked it up and pretended to smell it
so I could confirm to her that it's not
[ __ ] so I'm nothing and she was she was
like so extra she goes to me do you
think they did that on purpose and I was
like wow they did on purpose she was
like I don't remember they're racist by
the people in Spain racist and I was
like maybe maybe they did I was like
maybe they did maybe they knew that we
were black and they put [ __ ] on our
towel oh my don't know it she was like
that's disgusting I'm not having I'm not
having that and there's me not Paige
just leave it just leave leave it we're
bigger than that
leave it [ __ ] you leave it we're bigger
than that that's just [ __ ] leave it
bro I was so terrified I thinking if she
picks up this team and smells it she's
wet from my body stinks of [ __ ] bro I
don't know it was years ago it's never
happened since it never happened before
oh I was I was panic - traumatizing
number three here we go
you've got stories bro from I don't
remember these stories exist it feels
something like this yeah I don't you
mean number three huh D number three was
something that I never caught from yeah
but it wasn't my yard and I was so
unparalleled in my fear mmm so I can't
believe I'm telling this story this is
worse than any story I've ever taught
really this is so bad hit me it's just
so bad I could I have a second force no
you can't now can we sit let me sit and
get ready for this you can't now
okay so all right cool Coco Coco I'm
family I'm family oh here we go
save me I'm at a girl's house that I'm
seeing yeah I'm using a toilet yeah
I would never end under any
circumstances using a girls toilet in
her mom's house or her house if I didn't
need to for sure if I didn't need to
so I'm going down there and I'm trying
to take the quickest [ __ ] as possible so
she doesn't all gone for sure yeah I'm
sitting there trying to get it done and
I'm looking at the door and I'm so
panicked cause her mom and dad are in
the houses were and her sister so was
her her mom had dad Anna sister all in
the house yeah it was like in the
evening time like 10:00 or 11:00
yeah and I'm thinking [ __ ] I think
there's their main bathroom and I mean
they're taking a [ __ ] and I'm thinking
did I lock the door the door it was a
twisty thing so I didn't know if I
locked it on and I was like [ __ ] I don't
think about the door and in my head I'm
paranoid now now I'm paranoid all I can
think is someone walking in to see her
and I don't even think as it the worst
but I don't even think her mum and dad
knew I was there because a three-story
house okay so you can walk in and out
this house and the people didn't even
know you were there yes so I was like in
my head I'm picturing [ __ ] like they're
gonna walk in the mums gonna walk in she
doesn't even know I'm here and she's
gonna what the [ __ ] like she's gonna
walk in to see some black guy just
sitting on a toilet
she's gonna panic and then all these
scenarios go ahead this is gonna be the
worst day of my life when I was in my
life I'm a [ __ ] yeah and then to the
point where I can't take it anymore yeah
I need to check if I lock this door
so from I'm going I'm going a gonna
going wait for my next proper plop yeah
I'm right I'm just gonna go up onto the
door yeah so my shits by my ankle like
my husband my ankles and stuff like that
and I'm like bling here we go so I get
up and I'm laid off with the shuffling
to take this door go to check it I've
locked it yeah bless chilled
yeah turn around turn around
don't no no no no Jesus no I need to
cover my face so I've turned
and there is a trial of about three
Nuggets from the toilet seat one that's
falling off the front of the toilet
seats kidding I think I want us on the
bar I've never told anyone this story I
turn around and they were just like
going like a like a blood trail I was
screaming I was in my head I was
screaming and I'm thinking [ __ ] what am
I gonna do the door thing broke I'm
panicked
and I'm like [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] so
bro I'm panic panic panic and I get bad
tissue bear brushes bad cleaning
products everything and I'm just there
dealing with it and I pick up the bath
mat and stretch it like that such [ __ ]
so I'm stretching it like that and then
flinging it in there and then I think
I've cleaned up everything there's a
stain on the bath mat oh and also our
[ __ ] now I dunno
so I got the spray psyllium banks they
have Cillit bang in there so I've
sprayed the Cillit bang on the ting and
I'm like cool cool cool let's clean up
the carpet I've right tit there's bleach
in there fam so the thing was gray
losing color the thing was gray fam so
the whole thing is gray once I've
cleaned it the whole ting is great and
there was a bright white mark in the
shape of [ __ ] on the front of this
[ __ ] bar oh my god your day couldn't
get any worse
bro to this day I don't know what they
thought happened that's gone from a
quick [ __ ] to an absolute disaster oh my
goodness and obviously she knew a second
by the time will come back up that she
knew I was taking a [ __ ] yeah Rex cuz
I've been there about 15 minutes oh my
god I know who just we've just nothing's
normal said anything about it but
luckily that didn't last very long but
fam to this day I wonder when they would
to Nair for what the [ __ ] is that
what the flying [ __ ] is that why is it
why is there a white thing on my bath
mat bro I've never been so scared as I
was that day if I just kept my paranoia
to myself yeah the whole thing would
have been resolved never have happened
it would never have happened I was
panicked for
that's funny to me bro stuff like
farting [ __ ] stress me out to that level
this is why will not die that's not
definitely not why but I would never I
would never take it well I say never I
would rarely take a [ __ ] at work like no
matter which worker working because for
me I can't take I can't take like a
two-minute [ __ ] shame for me is an
ordeal read sign I'm gonna chill it's
not it's not spread calm
I wanna be relaxed when I found you know
I mean fam so this is why I can't I
caught you at work brokers for me if I
leave the floor for 10 minutes hell
could break loose yeah I mean how could
families exactly what you just said
happened to me three days ago at work
yeah when to take my morning Duke I
don't care cuz I hate being in my office
oh yeah so any issues to go on
government yeah but I don't want people
to know I'm going for a [ __ ] yeah of
course so I dipped went come back
sitting on my computer typing away one
yeah
- like quadrants away from me she's like
huh James I didn't think you were coming
back and I was just like she knows every
head I'm like she knows she knows she
knows I think her from me and she knows
didn't have an appointment she knows she
knows she knows she knows and I was just
like what and she's kidding at me she's
smiling family's that anything is coming
back like that little close-up I don't
think he was coming back it was like
[ __ ] you
shut your mouth [ __ ] you at the same
time [ __ ] you [ __ ] you shut up you don't
know about me you don't know my story
you don't know my [ __ ] stories leave
me the [ __ ] alone max let me [ __ ] in
peace brother why you going Baris know I
know [ __ ] Barris me let me Champy's
do you then now think sometimes girls
have done that to us like it goes on
some some girls just need to [ __ ] off
see everyone shits of course but you
know do you know do you sometimes think
that girls have taken shits in your yard
secretly or fight in your yard secret
did you ever think that I've never
thought about it but they probably have
they probably have they probably have
cuz more time especially if you're
seeing someone
mmm they would probably do the same [ __ ]
I think we do ie go and shower switch
your and take a [ __ ] huh come of course
but you don't no way think about it yeah
of course I don't wanna think about you
just want to block it out I feel like
every male doesn't want to know
your shits because of course there's
definitely been times in my life where
my goal at the time has gone into the
bathroom I've heard the shower will go
on
she's in there for however long I've
heard the shower will come off and then
I've heard the toilet flush so she
planned it right on the hole do you know
how I what I'm so paranoid when I do
this whole scheme about putting a shower
to play music on is when for some reason
I just think people are listening
I always think regardless of how much
noise I'm making like music and shower
I still think people can [ __ ] hear Oh
hundreds because there are times when I
[ __ ] bro it's loud when you don't you
know been holding it in bro this is like
you're running home to [ __ ] damn kind of
I've been holding it in mm-hmm
everything's going yeah yeah but as soon
as you let go is that it's that bullets
yeah absolutely
someone's earning but what makes it
worse is that you know when obviously
you leave the shower on it and you know
when you know no one's in a shower by
the showers running mmm because it
sounds loud yeah you know when someone's
in it because when they step in it goes
quiet goes quiet but it's the way it
trickles yeah yeah I think people think
that when I'm in the shower same I'm
thinking thank know I've gone for [ __ ]
because the war's been running for good
ten minutes and life changed that's
exactly why I think that's exactly why I
think I'm crazy it's so funny you said
that's exactly exactly word for word why
they think people are listening throat
that's exactly why they are annoyed and
then when I do get into it I think that
I think that they're thinking oh they
don't know no they don't bump it there's
been times where I've been on there the
music's on and a song will come but it's
been like ten minutes I'm ashamed and
the showers on and some like I don't
like comes on I change it nothing
you've proven the whole facade will gasp
and I'm lying the whole thing they know
they know they obviously don't know no
one gives a flying [ __ ] what I'm doing
in the bathroom breath but I panic about
it so [ __ ] much because it's so
discussed is like there's nothing sexy
about it and there's I just wonder one
my partner whoever I'm seeing at the
time or ever to know that I'm doing that
yeah right obviously it will get to a
stage of comfortability way it's just
gonna happen but for now as long as I
can avoid it and [ __ ] avoiding it Oh
bro right racks and void it [ __ ] that
was funny bro it's disgraceful I hate I
hate it I hate it rough every time we go
to a hotel where we go I'm thinking of
nowhere else she can go we're all
[ __ ] in the same toilet it's [ __ ]
horrible it's just a room it's one room
and a bathroom like she's gonna hear you
[ __ ] bro and that's the thing is in my
head as well I also think like if I [ __ ]
if I do even do the shower trick or
whatever if I [ __ ] come out obviously I
want to close the door there's no vents
in here so she can comment in two hours
time and I still know that there's a Sun
in there there's a sin it's not going
anywhere
I panic so much brother it's like in
stressful man somebody's to invent a way
that we can do this in secret I know I
know who's dressed funny there was a
speaking of like the whole thing perfect
example was in damn yeah when you were
in my room yeah and I had to take [ __ ]
yeah the the bathroom door was like
viscus like you can see like glassy tone
to it
as you can see through anything so you
can't you can't but you can
so you can see like silhouettes and Cher
so obviously I haven't do a [ __ ] I know
you were in my room and I I think I knew
you knew I was taking [ __ ] I can't
remember but you know I was gonna bar
from whatever but even then I'm sitting
there I look at the door that was like
caused to me like a foot away yeah and
I'm thinking if he looks he can see me
you see me sit in the [ __ ] toilet and
taking showers right now
so from I ended up twisting this way I
ended up twisting this way so you shat
side rights outside was it was
uncomfortable I'm never doing it was on
combat you know was actually mad was
very mad same situation I took a [ __ ] in
your room
mmm-hmm copy what is this talking like
this I know this is disgraceful this is
so disgraceful don't judge us on this
please please God I took a [ __ ] in your
room and I did the same routine shower
on this before went to shower shower
music on because I knew my [ __ ] was
going to be large okay feeling and I'm
thinking if I go now without anything on
this guy's gonna think I'm a maniac
this guy's gonna think what you just did
is so disgusting even though I knew you
knew I was gonna take yeah yeah yeah
yeah bro feel instincts kicked in at nah
nah because I was about sit down
speaking I know for a fact this is gonna
be loud yeah I hold it in that much
longer
you know it's painful yeah yeah yeah oh
my god that's the worst it's the [ __ ]
worst I hate it so much
it's so funny bro I know for a fact to
ever listen to this they do exactly this
of course I've called every was the
[ __ ] same oh that's so funny to me
that hurt my chest Jesus
Oh am i dead I'm good
same thing in terms of like the links
that you've gone mm-hmm what links have
you gone any because I know I've done
this when I was talking about like
there's bad times where I've talked
about busing earlier or whatever but has
it ever been a time where you've been
[ __ ] a girl you've come early you
didn't want her to know that you've come
early so you used any tactic possible to
disguise the fact that you've come early
so that you can get a chance to go back
to grab - I think I'm oh yeah I think
every guys done that to be fair there
was a time I was [ __ ] a chick and I
would you know when you just talk smack
from like from the jump not even not
when she was there but like what's up or
whatever I was talking the utmost
schmuck said we're gonna do this and I'm
gonna do that right a you know just the
smoke everyone wants to give mmm she
comes in now I started getting nothing
on she gives me a head for a bit hmm
and then we're [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] in
and then obviously I give her anal for a
bit too soon and then I just not like
then the sex in total forget the
foreplay forget all of that the sex in
total probably lasted five minutes and
she was like this is gross
this is gross she was it was tight to
hurt her a bit okay and I was like I'm
nearly done soon a firm a kind of dog
I'm nearly done so shut the [ __ ] up
that's not word for word I said where
you get the picture yeah no I don't
think I said - I'm nearly done I said to
myself that I'm nearly done so ignore
her yeah I think I I think I thought she
knew I was nearly gonna finish yes so
like telepathically I told her to shut
the [ __ ] up because I'm about to be done
so just firm it yeah I never told her
yeah yeah as soon as I bust mine are
pulled out chilled initially I thank God
because I've seen what's hurting okay
yeah yeah yeah I know did you come I was
like yeah that's right oh and that was
it oh never specs very good really oh my
god a one that comes to mind for me is
the time however many as soon as you ask
me that question I really knew what
story you're gonna tell me it's how many
stories so many times ah
actually um do you know which one it is
you thought me too because obviously
you're the one how about says you're
involved don't know what I definitely
don't know what she was a stripper
went back to hers get into it and be
specific because when you say it sounds
as if I went with you okay sorry sorry
sorry clarify okay so when you said uh
involves you all these men are gonna
think something else
okay right sorry sorry sorry sorry so to
clarify me if you had one in my out he
was with the one girl that had been with
us the whole night
I am I met another girl on my own she
invite me back to her afterwards said my
farewells to
you went back to hers we were getting
into it everything's going well and for
some reason I just bang early it must
have been like three four minutes in and
I'm like [ __ ] yeah
so mid-stroke I'm like cool babes
I need to pee it's just out what are you
talking about we're having sex in it
yeah like what do you mean I was I'm
really really sorry I was I've been
drinking a lot I need to pee like let me
come back and we'll go straight back
into it yeah went to the bathroom
splashed water on my face
gave the cheeks and slapped I'm looking
at my dad like come on bro yeah you're
better this get back into it
so we go back in and I'm panic now yeah
I think it I don't think I'm gonna get
to get up again all the stuff I've been
drinking about whiskey dick all this
stuff that's funny yeah so drinking
whiskey dick I'm not gonna be able to
get it up she's gonna cost me
she had confidence oh yeah she would
have happily been like what the [ __ ] is
this like get your dick hard from yeah
so I'm not [ __ ] so the first thing that
came to my mind was to randomly ring who
had pretend he drank me so when you
answered yeah I was like so I think I
rang you yeah
wait for you to answer wave I could see
on my phone when I connected yeah and
then pretended to answer the phone yeah
pretending that you drank me so I'm in a
room she's looking at me like why is it
kind of fact yeah and I'm like oh la la
Lala Lala Lala use okey dokey it's okay
it's okay everyone's no more and then
obviously I didn't explain to you that
I've just but I couldn't explain to you
why I'm calling you
so I'm just making general chitchat yeah
only delay tactic yeah
any delay and then she wants to get back
into it yeah she you see my dicks not
hard but she can understand why yeah
because obviously I'm on the phone to my
boy there's no reason for my think to be
hard at cetera so she starts sucking me
off whilst them on the phone and then
I'm talking and then it must have got
nice to me for a minute and I'm like
and immediately immediately the mood
changes from and you're like she's
sucking you off his G how you knew from
that one low noise I don't know your
whole tone dropped fab she's sucking you
off isn't she cuz I think in the
background I heard up I heard I heard
him as soon as you did that I've heard
justjust in a background you know we
just you think what as soon as that I
put put two and two together yeah [ __ ]
you flipped on I'm so angry at you like
oh why of all things to do why obviously
I didn't know the situation so why the
[ __ ] you calling me oh you were gunning
for me
I remember I felt so about you were
gunning for me but yeah luckily that
that sloppy top and the delay gave it
the delay I needed I've got back in the
game and we finished strong we finished
strong
but [ __ ] I have funny office it was
the story do four story that was funny
but yeah ma'am I think that's it rapid
e-wrap rapid e-wrap guys see you next
week